nous voilà donc dans le sud-ouest de la
france en impôts n'est pas s'il était si
facile à trouver il serait pas vraiment
super secret ce spot nom
pierre veut bien être notre guide
jusqu'à un bras du lac isolée au milieu
de la forêt
au fond c'est parti du lac il ya une
maison parfaitement intact
c'est indiqué nulle part
c'est loin mais je vous promets ça en
vaut la peine
nerveuse
après on va à new york commenter les
images et dès qu'on atteint 2 millions
de vues bah directs sont mariés dans une
chapelle de vegas
la visibilité est plutôt bonne on
atteint le premier plateau à 10 mètres
de profondeur
on y est
j'avais oublié à quel point les gens est
très superstitieux paris
et voilà
des choristes à
tout ça non
tu as vu ce qu'on aurait manqué si on
était resté sur le sentier
cascades et la vie sur la falaise
qu'est ce que c'est
je dis que j'ai vu un homme je te jure
je j'ai vu quelqu'un
c'est une histoire que les habitants du
coin connaissent mais dont ils ne
parlent pas ou alors tout bas comme une
histoire de fantômes
on les embête pas
et il ne nous embête pas en retour
mais ceux qui s'aventurent la hausse
c'est quoi cet abri
[Musique]
ne reviennent jamais
ted 3 kg en train de rêver
[Musique]
tu t'en
vas tu
[Musique]
du nord express
est
ce
[Musique]
là
abrités
guy a
le cinéma
je serai
prêt
on va les sauver
west je pense en fait ni chaud
c
amoura t out games
de fait sinon 10
aulas
[Musique]
vous cherchez un jour
quelqu'un
abba
[Musique]
qui ta fuite
est morte si tu veux mon avis il a été
torturé je veux que tu quittes cet
endroit tout de suite début tu connais
pas cet endroit fait mal ça va
je rentrerai pas à la maison tant que je
n'aurai pas trouvé qui avaient
tabassé à mort à bord était à la place
de ceux que tu vas voir à toi je te
conseille d'obtenir un l'égard des
nouveaux jeux auxquels frangin
ton père tu es mais à ce point là c'est
son amour pour toi qui l'a tuée
qu'est ce que tu fais avec ses tâches
c'est mon père qui me l'a donnée
[Musique]
lâche ça tu veux
faut reconnaître que tu es un sacré
numéro tuent seize argué qu'il est
mettre les choses au point hollande il
m'en faudrait non tu prends pas l'argent
du puits qui va mourir pourtant dumont
du nuage
edu menace de tuer tous les habitants
quand quelqu'un de méchant mer c'est une
bonne chose on est d'accord
j'en trouve un coeur qui bat
je veux connaître la vérité tu comprends
qu'est ce que tu as fais mon bébé
[Musique]
c'est pourquoi
je t'ai vision
je les couche sur le papier les gens et
pour les lire
il a dit que l'élan donne avec tous
l'habitude d'être à déconnecter
de la réalité t t il appeler ça être
dans la m
[Musique]
jusqu'à quand on verse tous
revient
je suis en plein traquenard commence un
traquenard
un jeu de piste de scott et son frère
avaient inventé une chasse au trésor
il fallait que je vienne en personne
pour essayer encore une fois ses oeuvres
nous publier ses papiers doivent être
rassemblés ils font les exemples il est
hors de question que vous voyez ces
papiers
elle refuse de me les donner je
récupérerai ses papiers pauvres
scott london ses livres m'ont changé
tu te rappelles le soin ou tu m'a
demandé si j'étais simple m j'ai fini
par y croire voilà le pouvoir de son
imagination il existe un moment
on peut y retourner
moi ce qu'on aime qu'est ce que c'est
une fois qu'on a résolu toutes les
énigmes et trouver tous les indices
mènent à une récompense
est-ce qu'il est barré
on doit en même temps
[Musique]
où c'était le fruit de mon imagination
7 oct
[Musique]
mister
k o
bonsoir
il est parti et les respects de pousser
leurs cours
[Musique]
est ce qui est un réel où c'était le
fruit mon imagination
[Musique]
pourquoi tu as besoin d'un coup
pour un coffre afin qu est ce qui vient
récupérer dans ce coffre-fort ya une
pierre est-ce que ça comme coffre fort
un france jaeger
j'ai un blanc
c'est un plan formidable
ingénieux épatant le plus génial de tous
les plans qu'on n'ait jamais eu
l'occasion de mettre à l'essai
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit la bouche
les gratte ciel de drogue en plein coeur
de stockholm ce gros bonhomme qui
restent plantés sur toi c'est moi ou
quoi évidemment chacun de ces cinq
immeubles mesure 72 mètres de haut à
l'exception du troisième qui s'appelle
l'immeuble cool j'aime ici deux fois
plus grand que les autres celle là
toutant pas que se trouve enfermé le
crif de la carélie la lampe torche tu
préfères mais est-ce que tu la veux je
veux pas très lumineuse alors ça me
paraît évidemment
[Musique]
à
j'y crois pas qu'elle soit et c'est
d'une caisse du ciel
je sais pas comment tu
aurais j'imagine que c'est dans ma
nature et j'ai toujours dit dédé
[Musique]
non
à gauche
l énorme match ac
ils sont
[Musique]
venus pour chicago
les
[Musique]
ospreys
mes muscles
tout au long de ce
mois
[Musique]
édifiant la finesse
you make me feel juice
everyone in africa
et une passe